if you are performing and you know how
to do the job great work from home on a
Thursday whatever you want to do do it
whatever suits your lifestyle but when
you aren't performing why are you
working from home like the people that
are around you are the people that are
going to teach you how to do your crafts
it's such a gray area cuz some people
see it as a perk a necessity but you're
never going to learn sitting on your own
at home I completely agree and just like
it's just a point of efficiency as well
you're not telling me a message on slack
or a message on WhatsApp it's quicker
and getting something done than asking
someone up your desk all for the the
hybrid model I enjoy the hybrid model at
the same time you know when you're in
the office those days are definitely
needed yeah